lui c'est aïe ça fait 18 ans qu'il dans
son envie transmettre sa passion du hip
hop à ses élèves
le but leur permettre d'apprendre se
surpasser et surtout acquérir les bases
que l'on soit amateur ou professionnel
grâce elle chorégraphe
[Musique]
en fait le délire si que je voyais aussi
à plein de jeunes quittant dans ma
situation avant moi aussi à mon tour
j'ai c'est de leur vrai mes potes comme
ça ils viennent danser plutôt que d'être
dehors et de faire n'importe quoi donc
bah c'est la base du hip hop à la base
ans et on est là pour créer au lieu de
détruire et de faire des bêtises donc
voilà canaliser cette énergie là avec
eux et faire en sorte que les y trouve
un épanouissement ou voir même une voie
professionnelle
ils sont 26 élèves à participer au stage
les ont entre 23 et 75 ans chaque jour
durant ce stage ils s'entraînent entre
1h et 1h30 pour perfectionner la
chorégraphie de taille qui mélange break
new style hype et popping des cours qui
plaisent aux aides
ouais ouais ça m'apporte des bases
puisque il ya aussi des gens qui dansent
mieux que moi et du coup je me cale sur
eux pour pour avoir un meilleur niveau
le hip hop c'est une passion et comme
j'ai l'intention d'en faire mon métier
donc du coup c'est pour ça que je prends
des sages comme ça pour à chaque fois
prouvé c'est pas un truc providence ou
dans une compagnie ou débattent elle a
fait vendredi 17 juillet un spectacle
sera proposé à 21h30 à la verrière au
grand public et celui ci est gratuit